all right good evening everyone
and welcome to this meeting of scrutiny
the first in this
municipal year um i'm councillor rob
chilton the vice chairman
i think um councillor action has just
been
unavoidably delayed who would normally
be cheering so hopefully he'll be able
to join us as soon as possible so i'll
just
get things started in the meantime um we
have a number of new members
with us today um just to say to those
people if anything
at any point is unclear or needs
clarifying
uh please do just drop a message and we
should hopefully be able to cover that
and make sure everybody knows
um what the procedures and what have you
are
um first item on the agenda is
attendances
um alex do we have any apologies
uh apologies have been received from
councillor james wright and
from richard rowe can must be
recorded um item two membership of the
committee
including the appointment to the chair
and vice chair
um that's just for noting is that noted
everyone
all right thank you very much um
counselor diagnol can't seem to hear us
um
not quite sure why that would be um
might be an issue with your laptop
possibly counselor
um
right okay it was everything all right
technically alex we should be able to
hear each other shouldn't we has anybody
else got a problem hearing
technically it should all be fine okay
well to those members who are struggling
just perhaps um make sure they perhaps
try their reboot in their machines or
whatever
um moving on terms of reference
item three again those are in our pack
uh everybody seen them and uh
again we do they're just for noting um
any comments on this
everybody happy with it
alex is there any change from last from
the terms of reference from last year
i'm not no okay right um
in that case since i'm not hearing any
uh
dissension we'll take those as read
item for the minutes of the previous
meetings everybody had sight of those
and if so are you happy they're a true
and correct record any points or any
comments
i appreciate there's quite a lot of us
that weren't even at that meeting so
hard to say
okay do they do they have to be moved
and seconded by somebody who was there
alex
chose this is an informal meeting you
only note in the minutes they'll be sent
to the next meeting for formal approval
smashing thank you john right in that
case if everybody is happy
with them as they are can we please note
them thank you very much
and alex and john could you just make
sure that if counselor acton
is able to join us can you just quickly
give me the nod either in the message or
just
hello me
item five declarations of interest um
it's basically for new members this is
just if anything is on the agenda
i'm sure you're aware that um you might
be impacted by
professionally or personally you can
just declare that
um just for the purposes of legal
legalisms um i don't have anything um
has anybody else got any other
declarations
i'm hearing uh stern silence which i'm
hoping indicates not
okay um
item six public questions have we had
any
no questions have been received from the
public smashing
um okay doke um
well say smashing obviously you know we
do want to make sure we get questions if
necessary from the public so
might be an idea if members make sure
that their residents are aware that that
is possible um in which case item seven
the budget update director of finance
um are they here
yeah thank you chair um just by way of
an update
for all new members but i think there's
probably some members here who
who have not attended meetings with in
the past so i'm graham bentley i'm
director of finance i took over from
nicki bishop
um just before the council budget
setting meeting in february earlier this
year
um so
we've we've had a difficult six months
and we've come off the back of
um a difficult 12 months in local
governments as well i think
just by way of before i start the and
run through the presentation briefly
which i know you've had um
so i won't dwell on that in significant
detail and i'll
i'll open up for questions at the end
but i think it's fair to say local
government finance can be quite complex
and
i'd just like to offer at the start of
the meeting if there's any questions
tonight obviously i'll answer them if
any questions that come up in the
meantime or issues that you may
have please whatever you do you must not
hesitate to contact us and i'll try and
help you
in the work that you do as part of the
scrutiny committee which obviously we
value
as officers as well um
i think just in terms of the
presentation for tonight i was just
asked
to provide an update on two areas the
first
was an update on um the out-turn
performance
and um and how we performed against
budget last year
and then the second one was to give an
update on our overall reserves position
so
i'll go through each of those in order i
think it's fair to say last year 2021
um i've worked for the council for a
good number of years now and i think
it's the most difficult
obviously for the council and for the
rest of local government
and for the local government finances
the stream that's put on us has been
immense
and that that's that's on the back of um
budget challenges and funding reductions
that we've
encountered over the last 10 years since
2010
where our overall spending power and the
resources available to us have gone down
by
over 26 and each and every year for them
10 years we've been faced with a
significant budget challenge
but i think it's fair to say that last
year was like no other
just to put it into context and there's
some big numbers here
across the whole of local government the
challenges it faced
um in terms of pressure for on
additional expenditure as a result of
corvid the impact that
corvid 19 had on our income streams
and also on our funding from council tax
and business rates was immense
and those figures across the country
were nearly 10 billion pounds
um what we did throughout the year
um we were continually updating and
revising our forecasts
and and we were continually providing
regular information to
mhclg i think one good thing that's come
out of last year is that
i think the government and particularly
the
the communities and local government
department
have really got into the detail beyond
local government finance and i think it
was evident
they didn't fully understand it at the
start of the year but
through the returns they we did through
the year
they eventually came up trumps and
provided funding
in total just over nine billion pounds
towards the overall pressure that the
local government faced
i think just just looking at the numbers
for trafford
in terms of the impact of covid that was
probably just
around 52 million pounds
that's a gross pressure but as i've said
obviously government provided
quite a number of different grants
towards that
um and also they brought in some other
measures that
helped us in effect reduce the impact on
the in year and i'll just briefly
explain that
so if you think we we obviously collect
and pay for our services
through council tax and also through the
collection of business rates
those two areas are something that they
call the collection fund
and we did experience deficits on that
collection from last year but what the
government did say is
um don't count those against your
out-term position for 2021 what we will
do is
we'll let you phase that and pay those
back over the following three years
so the government did bring in some
measures that helped us
so overall the net the net pressures
after
all that we're about eight million pound
on direct things related to call with 19
across the rest of the council's budget
and this is a difficult thing sometimes
to understand
is there were other budget savings
in the year and some of those if if i
use as an example
um government gave
probably from september onwards funding
what they call contain funding
this was funding to support public
health activities
uh and reduce the spread of the virus
there were quite significant sums of
money
so a lot of our public health work
or some quite material
um elements of public health work we're
able to be charged to some of those
external funding streams
so that's given rise to one dispense on
other aspects of the budget
so overall we reported at year end
an underspend of 2.8 million pounds
and what i've put within the
presentation um
is across some of those service areas
what some of the reasons were
which contributed to the variances
within some of the specific service
areas like i say
i will not i'll not go through those in
detail for time but i'm happy to take
questions after
in terms of reserves this is
this is quite an interesting picture in
terms of the council's reserves and i
think
anybody who's heard me speak at these
presentations before
will know that i've said that trafford's
got a relatively low level of
ear marked reserves so
on slide number seven there is
um a position statement that shows how
our
reserves have moved during the year so
we started offer to balance at 91
million
and they've gone up to in excess of 200
at year end and i think it's just
probably worth just
explaining that movement a little bit at
this stage because
whilst at face value it does sound good
news i think
the the point i want to make is that
increase is just really a temporary
increase
um and a lot of it is around how we've
accounted for things in our collection
fund so what what we will end up doing
is utilizing good chunks of that balance
throughout the course of 2122
um so in effect there's a lot of
commitments and also
for those who were at budget council and
saw the budget reports there was quite a
significant use
and planned use of our reserves um
particularly for 21 22 and 22-23
to cover the ongoing impacts of corvid
and i'll name just one
you probably you might be aware that the
council
along with the other manchester
districts received
dividends from manchester airport um
to the tune of about five and a half
million pounds well those dividends
ceased being paid in 2021 as you can
imagine
and the indications that we get
from the airport is that obviously that
position will continue into the medium
term until
until the airport recovers so these are
things that obviously our reserves
are meeting and trying to bridge those
budget gaps
in into the medium term uh just looking
at slide eight and i've tried to
present that picture as we see it
um across the next three years and
you'll see how those reserve balances
reduce
and it's quite it's quite a stark
reduction but i think i just
like to say that that is broadly as we
planned when we set the budget that
those reserves would end up
down at those levels and i think just
just a couple of things to add to that
is obviously
whilst reserves we need reserves to
support our budget position
reserves will never be the answer to our
budget challenges because budget
challenges
occur each and every year the recurrent
and obviously reserves once they've been
used that they've gone
so they might just help to soften
um budget rounds but then they
by no means give us a recurrent answer
to our budget
budget issues um just one thing i'd like
to add in terms of
nationally where we're going um the
public accounts committee
um sat in may and looked at the impact
of corvid 19 on council budgets
um what they've
tried to impress on mhclg
is that as part of their preparations
for the
comprehensive spending review that'll
take place later this year
they've asked mhclg to make sure they
feed into that
the longer term impacts that local
government will see
we'll see flowing from corvid 19
they acknowledge this cost so we're
still working on trying to understand
how long those impacts will last um
the other thing that they want to do is
obviously give local government
certainty because at the moment
we don't have any funding certainty
beyond the current financial year which
which makes our financial planning
um quite difficult
i think just to finish off i'd just like
to say that obviously
we're continuing to monitor our
financial position
we've just completed a draft of our
period two
budget monitor position that will go to
executive in july
um and obviously we started the budget
planning round
for 22.23 because obviously we're still
faced with that challenge of a budget
gap into the
into the short and medium term as well
so
um there's a lot of activity on on
finance as you can imagine so
i'll finish there and more than happy to
take any questions
anybody's got thank you very much graeme
um we'll ask members just to indicate
either in the chat or by using that
little
hand thing on the reactions on zoom if
you want to ask
anything i will ask something first then
if i may well
members want to speak um graham where
capital projects
are happening which i appreciate
slightly off on this book
it has been a concern of mine
particularly because i mean it's more of
a specific
instance um whereby um a school
where i'm chair as a major capital works
at the moment
and there have been some issues about
some of the costs of that capital
project being pushed onto the school's
budget
um which obviously in cases where it's
something wouldn't
otherwise have is appropriate in some
instances where it's
things that the school that the council
are requiring rather than school
the place for examples of places is
inappropriate
i'm a slightly concerned that might be a
theme and i think i would just like a
bit of reassurance that isn't
happening across the board
i i'm not aware i know
the council i think has been challenged
by way of some of the allocations it
received the majority of the councils
spend on capital
is funded from external resources
namely capital grants and and the big
recipients of that is the education
capital program
uh whereby we've spent
uh quite quite a lot in recent years and
it
it probably i was just trying to think
of the figure i can't but
in respect to school's basic need and
extra place provision
um i'm not aware
it occurs now i do know
in the past schools have received um
direct formula capital um
if there's any specific examples i'll
take them back and like i said i'm not
aware that that's occurring across
across the piece on our schools program
at all but
more than happy to take that back i
might flag a specific with you offline
then
well i'm more than happy to feel that
question separately
yeah thank you much obliged council
proctor please
yeah uh yeah thank you thanks for your
update uh green that's uh that
that's helpful to find out where we're
up to obviously the main emphasis is
is on the impact of covered on budgets
which is as you show them quite
significant
but we did have going back some time
quite a bit of analysis to show that
uh brexit would have a disproportionate
effect on traffic because of the a lot
of the european based businesses we have
in trafford
so we're expecting to see some sort some
sort of negative
impact there i just wondered are you
seeing any signs of that yet
um is that accounted for in
the budgets as we go go forward possibly
it might be a bit too early to see any
impact
but i just wondered what your thoughts
yeah it's a really good question i think
the focus of our
uh activities prior to covered 19 was
what will brexit mean for us then
then we had last year it's it's not it's
not off our radar at all i think
i would mentioned earlier one of our key
funding streams is from business rates
um and i think it's fair to say that
probably over the last
two years we've seen a decline on our
overall business rates baseline
and there's a number of competing things
for that and brexit undoubtedly is going
to have an impact now i know we've done
assessments on that
and i think it's just something we're
going to have to watch as the year
progresses and i think we'll be building
that into the budget plans as we go on
and understand that better
um but it i
i just think it's a real difficult one
to see at the moment because
when you look at business rate income
the amount of volatility last year
on the basis that half of our properties
which are
classes retail probably didn't pay any
rates and the government paid those
bills by way of grant
and we wait to see how those bounced
back this year
i suppose a difficult thing for us to be
to understand well what what's a covert
impact and
recovering but where's brexit now coming
in particularly around some of the
some of the buildings and properties
around trafford park
so it's not off the radar at all and i
think it's one that we're watching next
year just to see what the impact is on
on them particularly on business rates
yeah it's definitely something you need
to keep keeping an eye on absolutely
definitely because those those
businesses hit by covered and hit by
some aspects of brexit as well it could
have quite a significant impact for us
in the next few years thank you thank
you councillor
um uh councillor carter please
thank you chair um i hope you can hear
me brian thanks for presentation
um recovery from covey
and uh commercial and economic activity
uh rebooting are there anything
uh potential to look again at
opportunities for generating
commercial income uh either more of our
new sources
um as businesses get that going again
yeah thanks for the question good
question i think um
the council does have a an asset
investment strategy which it started a
few years ago
um it's made significant investments
and will still look to make investments
going forward
part of part of the budget plans for
2122
assumed additional income from our
investments and just
just to qualify what that meant is that
last year i think the figure that we got
in terms of net returns from commercial
assets and our investments was in the
region of seven million pounds
that that's a net figure i must add i
think when you look at the gross returns
we're probably in the region of 16 17
million pounds but what we're doing is
we make provision for repaying debt
we put monies aside into risk reserves
but what what's been happening is some
of our investments are quite short-term
and just to explain that we give
we give quite a number of um developer
loans
so loans that support the building of
infrastructure
once that infrastructure is built and
the developer then sells that on we then
get repaid so we've had
instances like that this year and
therefore we'll be looking if the
opportunity arises to recycle those
funds
to to in effect maintain those income
streams at the levels
of about six or seven million pounds so
i think at this stage we're not
necessarily looking to grow on those
levels but to maintain the income
streams that
we are reliant upon for our budget
thank you yes that's all right
councillor carter do you have anything
else to ask dory
is it happy with that content thanks
chair
right um i haven't had any other
indications
uh so far graham so i think with that we
can
digest what you've sent us because the
slides are still available and i've no
doubt that if
any members have any supplementary
questions that occur to them later
i'm sure that you'll be able to field
those for us working
yeah that's fine yeah thank you we'll
hear more from you thank you we'll let
you go okay
yeah thanks very much thank you bye
smashing right moving on um
the next item is regarding the cladding
um
now there's nothing in the supplementary
agenda either
alex we got anything for this uh
originally i thought it was going to be
a written report but instead it's going
to be a verbal report given to us by
graham scott today
oh okay and he's with us great thank you
yeah apologies for that um chair um i
did agree or written a verbal report
this time but
in future if you'd like written reports
from us we're more than happy to do that
um as an introduction because it's the
first time i've been to this committee
my name's graeme scott
i'm one of the executive directors at
trafford housing trust
and i've got a responsibility for the
whole property portfolio for the whole
for the organization where i just wanted
to start even though we said we talked
about cladding
was just to start off with our whole
approach to fire safety
because i think it's just really
important to just highlight what we've
been doing over the last number of years
and what i would say is as an
organization
this is probably of this is our number
one priority in terms of getting fire
safety right across all our 9000 homes
within trafford
and what we've tried to do is adopt a
real customer-centric approach where we
put the right things in place for our
customers
and in doing that we've got a
comprehensive approach across all our
homes
but in particular we've been really
concentrating our complex buildings
because we often talk about our high
rise but we've also been putting the
same efforts into our lower eyes
and into our sheltered schemes because
they're just as important to make sure
we get them right and what i'd like to
say
first off is that in doing that we have
got actually
fire risk assessments across all our
properties which are in date
and you know meet the relevant standards
we're in a really positive place there
and what they help us to do is pull that
program investment that we need to do
in all our homes within trafford and
what we've been really concentrating on
since probably 2019
is a fabric-first approach where we
invest in getting the
building right and the compartmentation
right of all our
homes and make sure the fire stoppings
right
that's standard because that's what we
believe makes the biggest difference
in protecting our customers and making
sure their homes are safe places to live
and since doing that program if you take
the high rise first of all
we've been for every high-rise property
we own we have
invested in all the communal areas and
all the areas of that building
making sure that they are fire safe and
as part of that we've actually been in
over 700 properties now um making sure
that that property is a safe place to
live so a really positive place to be
we've only got about 700 so
we've really tackled the root cause
there and make sure everything's correct
what we've also been doing is the same
work in our shelter schemes
and our walk-up flats and that work
across our shelter schemes is also
complete
and we've actually now moved on in our
shelter schemes starting looking at
renewing the fire alarms in those blocks
and by the end of this year we'll have
replaced about 50
of the fire alarms within those
properties bringing up to you know high
quality standards
and today's modern standards so again a
positive step forward
and then i walk up flats again we do
that same compartmentalization work that
we're doing that high-rise and shelter
and that will be finished for the end of
this year so you know we believe that
takes us to a really positive place
making sure that all our customers homes
are safe and
and the final part of that is around
doing a door program
and making sure again that they are up
to the right standards and we're about
50
the way through that program as well
which will be finished over the next two
to three years
so a huge investment in fire safety
over the last two or three years the bit
we do talk about a lot though as
you said in the introduction chair isn't
cladding and you know that's really
important that we get that right
and you know that has created i suppose
a lot of concern for our customers
and you know we have been really trying
to get that to the right place
but just before i talk about where we
are i suppose i'd like to issue an
apology first of all because
we did have a press article recently in
the men and
local papers around the noise of the
works causing and
we recognize as an organization that's
not ideal we recognize there's more
people working from home at this moment
in time
and that disturbance to you during the
day either you know must make it really
difficult to live and work for people's
homes of people as people are doing
these days in the current situation
but again we also recognize essentially
if we don't do those fire safety works
then homes you know wouldn't be safe to
live in so unfortunately we do
have to do it but whilst we are doing
that we are we are listening to
customers
and we are trying to i suppose make it
as less in truth as
intrusive as possible so some of the
things we've been doing over recent
months since we did get those complaints
in
is we've been talking to our contracts
about working only within those core
hours
making sure that that really noisy work
isn't first thing in the morning or
lasting at night with improved
information in all our tower blocks and
they've all got information on the
noticeboards now is exactly what works
happening each week
and again just trying to really improve
that communication i'm sure we can get
it better still
and we'll continue to work on it but we
have been really trying to get that
right
to make sure that we are meeting those
customers needs
in terms of the actual cladding work
itself um
or as we've said before to scrutiny
committee when a colleague of mine
attended
all the i suppose old cladding has now
been removed
and those blocks have been classed as
safe we've been able to remove the
fireborns from those blocks
and really it's just now a job of
replacing that
and may return them back to the state
where they were before but with safe
cladding on
and making sure that all the fire
stopping installation everything's done
correctly
the first tower which is empress that we
start on will be finished in july or
towards the end of july
so we are now seeing the light at the
end of the tunnel
and then we'll see us work through the
other tower blocks to
complete the final one before the end of
this calendar year
so very early in december so we have now
got the clear time scale the line of
sight to get all that work completed
it has taken us and we admit it's taken
us a lot longer than we ever anticipated
but that's because we've had to do more
works to make sure those homes are safe
and again whilst we recognize that's
caused more disruption for our customers
the most important thing has been to get
this right for those customers
and ensure again that they're safe in
their homes because that's what we want
they want them to be confident and safe
in their homes
whilst we have been doing that work so
we have also been
listening to our customers are saying
and i said we've tried to improve our
communication
but also another thing our customers
have been telling us is the parking is
not adequate in the blocks
and therefore we have over recent months
been working on
additional parking again to make sure
the access is safe in and out those
blocks
and there will be new temporary parking
facilities while the works going on
which will be ready in early july on the
tamworth blocks in old
trafford so what we're going to have
there again is just an improvement to
that to again to make sure
that we aren't blocking roads and make
sure customers got safe access to the
homes
or the fire service or other means of
emergency service
i suppose the last point that i wanted
to finish on before i take any questions
was just sprinklers because that's often
a question we get
where we are we're looking at sprinklers
for our tower blocks
um what i would say on that is uh most
people where we're
part of a wider group now called l and q
and
l and q have probably about 280
tailblocks
and a number of complex buildings like
we have complex buildings shelter
schemes floor rise and tower blocks
and therefore as a group we are looking
into
what the best route is to whether
sprinklers are needed or not needed
and we are doing a detailed piece of
work as group
as that and we will look to follow what
that group advice comes out
we are likely to get to a conclusion
that around the autumn of this year
where we'll be able to give much clearer
information about what we
intend to do with that but we know we
are treated very seriously
and we are looking the best research to
find out what the best thing to do is
again to keep customers safe um in the
meantime we'll continue to
con work with that fabric first approach
making
sure all our homes are safe um and
continue to make sure that you know our
customers got good
quality homes to live in and that's
the key bits to the update but i'm happy
to take any questions thank you very
much graeme um
again if i could ask members if you
would like to ask graham anything if you
could indicate in the chat or if you're
unable to do that for some reason to
raise the hand on the reactions and i
will just start with one before we move
to other speakers
graham i got the impression i mean we
haven't any clifford members on the
committee but i mean from what i knew
i understood of the situation a major
beef that the
tenants had in that press coverage was
the communication issue and the fact
that they were unable to get hold of
anybody
um who would take ownership of their
concerns
um i mean you have highlighted a few
things you have
any processes changed or because i mean
that is concerning
yeah and i always find it difficult if
customers
say this struggle to get hold of us
because that's how we want to be we
don't try and work well as an
organization but we do recognize
at times you know we are not as big as
the council we are a big organization
and we don't get things right so if
customers have struggled to get hold of
us we do apologize first of all because
it shouldn't be the case
um we have got clear information getting
our notice about how
customers can contact us and i think
what i'd like to reiterate
is probably really important they talk
to others and organizations in traffic
housing trust
and not to the contractors on site
because sometimes messages get lost
there and it was managed in the works
not settings the contractors so it's
important they take to us
we haven't necessarily changed any
process or practices
but what i would say is that you know we
have got a clear
um call center or hub with the text
calls
we have made it clear to those if we do
get calls around the tower blocks
around communication where they should
come to and they know they're coming to
my team and that property team and
i'm paying you know utmost attention to
this so
if they do come in i will pay personal
attention to and make sure
those customers get those questions
answered as quickly as possible
i mean what just just on that forum to
speak is graham what i would say is that
some local authorities and things
sometimes do
make sure that their contractors are
clued up with the answers to some of the
questions
because human nature dictates that they
will sometimes stop a contractor and say
do you know what's going on
so you might want to possibly think
about that you know even if it's not
detailed responses at least just the
facts
no and happy to take that on board again
generally try and steer them away from
the contracts because we i believe we
can give better information but
i think actually that's a really good
point on some of those simple things if
we get that right with the contract we
can address them quickly so
happy to have a look at that thanks
great we'll have councillor thompson and
then councillor win stanley councillor
thompson please
thank you chair thank you graeme can i
ask how
how this has been financed and will any
of those
costs be passed on to tenants and
residents
going forwards so at this moment in time
it's been financed completely through
our funds
in terms of how that will be financed
well i say complete between
our funds we we have there is also
government
grant and support going into that and
that will the full amount of that will
be determined once the schemes have been
completed
and there may be also a legal process
again which i can't talk about here we
have to go through
with the contract who did the works as
well so the the different elements in
looking how that's going to be financed
but at the moment it's been financed
between ourselves and government grant
that we've actually received for those
works
in terms of taking that forward and
passing on to our tenants
no we're not looking to pass any of
those costs back on to
those tenants or customers um so um
you know that's because that's the
simplest answer thank you
uh councilwind stanley please ah thank
you chair i had three questions one of
them has just been asked by uh
councillor thompson and graham i'm
greatly relieved to hear that the
the cost will not be uh if i want to do
you cut your answer correctly the cost
will not be passed on to tenants
um in increased rents or anything else i
think that would be
uh probably that will be criminal uh the
second question i know you answered in
the um
in the presentation but the the the the
link dropped out and
i didn't i didn't get that that didn't
get the answer but when will the
work on the cladding be finished so the
final block
will be december so the first block will
be completed in july or towards the end
of july
the final block early december brilliant
thank you and the final question is
around communication because
um ellen q uh took over the traffic
housing trust just as i was becoming a
counsellor
and there was real concerns amongst the
the tenants in my award that
communication would suffer
and certainly from my experience when
one company takes over another they tend
to centralize
they tend to centralize the the back
office such as communication
so so when you say that there's now the
dedicated call centers are they still
based up in trafford or they've been
relocated down into uh l and q's
heartland
no there's been no services really
located at this point in time so they're
still they're still based in trafford
um there's no at this moment in time
we're still working
as a i suppose a subsidiary of l and q
so therefore none of our services at
this point have changed
okay are there plans to change them uh
again i don't have that detail but those
conversations will be ongoing all the
time in reason
you know how we deliver the best service
as a group for our customers
but i don't have the detail myself
around you know whether we plan to
change our services in the future
but you know i suppose what the
priorities is for us as an organization
is to provide that best quality
information and best quality service for
our customers
and that doesn't change whether we we're
a standalone organization or
all with parts of l and q i know thanks
for i mean i i get that completely but i
said the residents concerns that they're
going to end up speaking to people down
in um
i kind of don't even know what else
headquarters is so long and i'm guessing
by their name
that they'll be the concerns the same
side of concern the residents had with
the um
with the other services that been
outsourced in in trafford where the end
of speed didn't speak to people
not the local area i'm just raising that
concern no doubt the next time in the
subsequent time you appear before
before the scrutiny committee will carry
on asking the same question yeah and
then there may be more information on
that in the future
you know again we live in a very agile
world these days and
you know the there are the people people
can work anyway and
i think this proves tonight that you
don't need to be in the book at this
moment in time
to to answer your question is you know
all our services still provided
from the existing staff within tht and
uh none of those services moved
okay brilliant appreciate it i think
certainly that's something we can keep
on the back burner and make sure perhaps
we
um have future conversations about in
this committee if there's going to be
um structural changes and to thc and i
mean personally our
speakers and most of the um social
housing stock in my ward is
held by another housing association
who's call center friendly i'll be
amazed if they know where traffic is
but um so i mean any improvement on that
is always a always beneficial to me
thank you
graeme um councillor dr barclay please
thank you chairman and thank you to
graham for your presentation and
obviously for all the work that you're
doing on cladding it's hugely important
and um
you know something that we must take so
so seriously and
just want to to really follow up on
something that really uh councillor
chilton just raised at the end there but
obviously thc is probably our biggest
housing provider in the borough but
we do have other uh housing providers
and i just wondered
i lost you i lost your um oh
definitely okay i sorry
yeah i'm so sorry well first of all
thank you graeme for coming to committee
and explaining what tht are doing about
cladding
because i'm sure all of us feel it's a
really really important issue
and the safety of our residents is
absolutely paramount
and and obviously i was saying that tht
is probably our biggest provider of
social housing in the borough but there
are as councillor chilton has said other
housing providers and i just wondered
whether you are working together
with the smaller providers is there
perhaps an alliance
and so that you can share best practice
on what you're doing because obviously
it's great to hear about tht and i know
you can't speak for others but obviously
just maybe spread
good practice and to bring in other
providers so that
every resident um has a you know um
increased safety uh as a result of the
actions that could be taken
so comment on that please yeah i know we
do work with other providers and that
that's really important as an
organization
actually ian wallace who has come to
this
committee before and has talked he's
actually now got a group role within l
q which is i suppose why i'm here
tonight rather than him
but one of the things he did while he
worked in tht
was set up a fire safety group that
involves
a number of organizations country-wide
large and small
and ian is one of the founding members
and still sits on that
and you know helps use his specialism
what we've learned
to help you know direct and support
other organizations
um you know and we work with smaller
organizations
on a range of areas right across our
business and ellen q do as well again
a different example but l and q in their
development function
support bam organizations across london
to develop new homes
in a safe way and they deliver them for
them and then provide them to that
organization once they've been built
so as a wider organization we're working
with a large number of smaller
organizations
and yes we want to continue doing that
because you know we're all trying to
achieve the same thing at the end of the
day
we all want you know good quality
housing for customers to live in
across the country so yes working
together keeping what we do
can i just follow that up with another
question oh thank you very much so could
i just ask you i mean how much
engagement are you getting from other
uh housing providers within the borough
because my concern is
if thd doing great work that's fantastic
but we have residents living with other
um housing providers so i just wondered
if you knew
what kind of engagement you're getting
yeah no in terms of um
other registered providers for the
housing associations we have you know
really
good contact and really good influence
and support and
again the council adrian's team and you
know um
richard ross team supporters on that and
they've you know they put great
structures in place so we can meet
work with those of the local housing
associations and work together
so i think there's a fantastic dialogue
between those organizations you know
and we're talking to likes of great
places or railroad valley and on a daily
basis across our teams again
as i've said you know strong influence
there from the council supporting us to
do that
i suppose where we probably have less
influence and less conversations is
with some of those private rented
organizations that are out there
who you know don't work as close with us
so that's where i say there's less
contact
and where we have less influence and
less conversations
okay that's okay counselor thank you
thank you
i'm sure you'd all hoped that you'd send
the back of my slightly grumpy chairing
uh when i packed in as mayor um so you
will all i'm sure i'll be delighted to
know that councillor acton
has now joined us so thank you dave i am
delighted to see you
and councillor butz i think was the next
speaker
thanks very much rob for standing in
whilst i was trying to get on but uh
made it eventually but yeah
a real really big thank you to you so
who who is the next speaker
counselor but counselor booked
are you there he's frozen
until he unfreezes
no well we can't see him then
he must be catching it off me
is there anybody else wishes to speak
whilst we wait for
councillor
sorry we're on item nine by the way dave
um yeah yeah
yeah right
so how are we are we done if there's no
other questions
on this item
yeah and
i don't think dylan's
able to speak is he is is it completely
frozen
counselor but has dropped off the call
right okay
okay right yeah
jed did you want to speak i was just i
think councillor butch had
left and was attempting to come back so
you might repair
right
are you there dylan
no no no i think i think if he's got a
question he could
he can send send that through email
to us he's now returned
yeah so graham
graham scott can i thank you for coming
along and i'm sorry that i missed the
beginning and the halfway through
and justin cat caught the end so
thank you very much for coming along
tonight and thank you for your time
today and again if counselor but does
have a question
more than happy to answer that at a
later time yes sorry can i come in
please
ah yes yes you can yeah yeah i'm sorry i
just had an unstable
connection there for the last few
minutes just tell me about it
right yeah it's just a quick question
thanks please uh
it's based around the the cladding
situation but in in
practice she's on grenfell a little bit
uh in what happened in the sense that
you know the fire what it concerns me is
the
uh how the truffle house interests or
lnq
are dealing with things like evacuation
procedures because pretty
we've not had a situation uh like that
of course but
uh it does seem to concern me that if
there was
uh in terms of evacuation because
obviously we have lots of vulnerable
people living in
trafford housing trust accommodation and
you know and uh and multiple occupations
so
and do you does the association have
that kind of
the trust have that about processes in
place and procedures and how do they
get the attendance to know what to do
and how to
sort of respond uh perhaps you know to
get to particular points where they need
to uh
i know there's sometimes a bit of a
turnover in people as well and how this
will deal with
uh refreshing any kind of uh procedures
they may have
thank you yeah no this is a great
question and um
so on each um complex building so
whether it's high rise low rise
um or sheltered we will have
a plan in terms of what customers need
to do in terms of that property
now sometimes that will be evacuation
sometimes that will be a
put policy depending on individual
building and that will depend on a
number of factors whether in terms of
whether it's got a fire alarm in place
and the age of the population there
the safety measures within that block
but in deciding
what that policy is and what that
process is
we're in full consult we will have
advice from a dedicated fire officer
um who specializes in that and we'll
also do it in full consultation with the
local fire brigade
so they will talk to us about what the
best method for each of those
is so yes we will have that for each
block and that's in place
those customers are informed um when
they move in but
you know on a regular basis that
information will also be on their notice
boards and yes they will get regular
updates
about if that changes or anything
different they need to do so for example
when we were doing the first part of the
works the cladding
we did change that pro originally we had
a step up policy
but whilst we were doing some of the
works we did have an evacuation policy
which applied to one floor up one four
that floor down
in terms of if there was a fire in that
block and when that change happened
we communicated that with all those
customers and then when we've changed
back to stay put policy
again that communication has gone out
again so what we do all the time is make
sure that we've got
an agreed process with the fire service
and the fire officer
and then we make sure that
communications with our
customers okay thank you
okay yep now is there any other
questions
um chair could i just add would it be
possible
could if we perhaps can have a written
update on this at some stage
when things are a bit further down the
line and obviously if any other
ish concerns are raised we can perhaps
one of his comments could join us again
yeah i think that would be useful
yeah and and then that apologies chair
next time more than have to do a written
update
um again if if we want to leave it a
couple months and then
do it once we you know got that first
block handed over maybe the
second third handed over and we can give
you a written update then again
i'll do it on the wider fire safety um
process that we're going through
yeah excellent okay well it remains for
me
just to thank you graeme for for coming
along
i'm sure it's been much appreciated by
um oh i've just got somebody up here me
oh it's a
councillor uh dr karen barkley she just
wants to ask a question before you leave
thank you chair it's really more to
yourself and the vice chair
i mean it's obviously really important
that we hear from tht
and our housing associations but i think
it has been raised that you know
private housing providers um are perhaps
less likely to be engaged
is it possible for us to hear from
someone within the council or house
housing
about how cladding is being tackled in
the private sector
please yeah i mean i'm
i'm not sure how many properties there
are in trafford
in relation to that but i think the
question can be asked
um and and we can do that yeah
let's ask the question of the housing
officers if we've got
if we've got those kind of properties
here
okay so thank thanks again graeme
um look forward to maybe seeing you
at a a future meeting but
much appreciated by it yeah thank thank
you thank you seeing that
okay i have a nice evening bye yeah
thank you
right the next item is item nine
uh which is the homelessness in trafford
alex who who's going to present this
we have adrian fisher in attendance
yeah yeah okay adrian
are you with us yeah yes thank you
thank you chair um good evening
councillors um
uh for those who don't know me i'm
adrian fisher i'm director of growth and
regulatory services
at the council and um
i'm here to just present the item on the
homelessness survey
uh so this uh hopefully you will have
seen
uh the report uh that's been put
together
um and and that's been circulated uh
earlier uh the context for this
is that uh historically for a number of
years
uh the statutory housing service which
is known as
host which is housing options service
trafford
has been outsourced uh lately with um
salex homes um but from first of april
it's been brought back in house so it's
a service run within the authority the
same as um
you know man many others in the normal
way
and this service provides statutory
duties
primarily under the housing act for uh
the prevention and assistance
of people either at risk or
uh directly affected by homelessness
um so we were kind of about three months
in now on that so it's quite timely i
suppose to
to to to have an overview as to how
that's going
um we uh pre-pandemic
we we had a reception
at the sail water side um which
as i say historically has been the hub
of where
uh people have received help and advice
as regards homelessness
obviously with the pandemic
unfortunately that have to close
but we're now uh able to resume some of
that
on an appointment basis um but but what
the pandemic has done is enabled um a
lot more i suppose agility for
a remote um service delivery and helping
people in other ways so
uh that's something that hopefully we
can take the best of that forward
uh for the future looking then
the the performance of the team and
the workload that's received um you'll
see that the
the applications um uh received
ver varies quite uh markedly uh
over time i mean it's sort of since the
start of the year it's really been a
a low uh at the 42 uh
per week um up to uh about um
uh 85 but but with the sort of
steady range perhaps around 55 to 65
um so so it's quite a it is a varied but
it's a fairly constant workload as
you can see from that now there are
um the homelessness duties do divide
into
slightly different ways um so
so we have a prevention duty which is
as the name suggests essentially trying
to
help people who are at risk of
homelessness
uh really avoid that situation and
intervene
and try and um get in there and and
prevent
people getting into further difficulties
then there are as well called the relief
duty which is um
really there for people who are are in
in immediate need
and um in need of of direct assistance
and then there is a a main duty which is
primarily addressed
for those who are in priority need
um and that's a longer term commitment
um uh for certain groups of people who
uh really need um the highest level
of assistance so you can see from the
the table there
uh in the report a bit of a snapshot in
time um
that we have large groups of uh numbers
in in each of those categories
um working through the system but
obviously the hope being that if we're
effective in our prevention duty
that limits the numbers that will then
go
through on some of the later stages
turning then to the number of households
seeking advice
uh again quite a kind of lumpy graph
there that
shows that that varies quite markedly uh
from
week to week um so range of sort of 13
through to
the 57 um and that's a service
again we can obviously offer to try and
uh help people
uh as as much as possible now i suppose
um the very visible side of of
homelessness
is is sometimes seen as rough sleeping
but of course you could um
actually that's a really tiny proportion
of the issue
as you can perhaps see by comparing the
numbers
so the numbers of rough sleepers
shown on the chart there um really the
highest we've ever achieved in recent
times has been about six
um and at times we've been uh thankfully
down
uh to zero and i'll explain a little bit
later
um we're sort of at a fairly steady
state now
uh around the sort of twos and threes
um so that that really is obviously the
most extreme
uh end of homelessness but the vast
majority of people we have effective
interventions uh for so part of that
picture
of those um uh interventions
is a temporary accommodation um and you
can see
that the numbers they're uh
reasonably steady um in the range
between about 120 in
the mid 130s so there's a steady
throughput of people going through that
system
and at least being provided with
accommodation when they need it most
part of that assistance to people
there is at times need for bed and
breakfast accommodation
generally to be avoided if we can but
that
um you can see that um you know there is
a
really an ongoing need for this
um uh and the numbers do
vary um the most we've seen so far this
year
has been uh 24 uh individuals
um um but it's perhaps more typically
around
the the mid teens um so
something that we would obviously look
to reduce as
far as possible now the other thing that
we
have to um uh bear in mind and i know
some of the councils on the call will be
particularly aware of this is that we
we do get out of bow replacement so in
other words
other councils in particular in greater
manchester
um will place uh their
homeless people in trafford where the
need arises
and um uh there is an obligation of the
housing act uh to notify ourselves
um and that's something that we've
really tried to
push with uh our neighboring authorities
to make sure this is done to make sure
we understand uh the picture in terms of
these out of area placements so at the
moment
it's primarily manchester city council
who are placing people into
trafford and as you can see we've had 32
notifications
uh since the first of april
and one of the
properties which some people will be
aware of is
the amblehurst hotel um but but there
may be others at times as well
uh and um if we get these notifications
then that's very helpful because we can
try and ensure that there are
proper support services in place
so that's a bit of a an overview of the
kind of workload and the service
uh delivery uh of the team
perhaps just then to outline a few of
the the the challenges and particularly
in relation to
uh the the recovery uh from
uh kovid because as many will be aware
there have been certain
exemptions certain provisions through
the pandemic and notable amongst these
is has been a moratorium on evictions
but that came to the end uh in uh on the
31st of may
um and so this may mean that we start to
see
more pressure on our housing services as
some of that kind of filters
uh through the system the other thing
that of course we are
always uh aware of in trafford is
that uh house prices uh either on the
northwest or certainly greater
manchester
context are generally very high um
and that applies not only to buying a
home but also renting
one as well um and um if you look at the
the charts you can see a comparison
between
um the local housing allowance which is
um
uh sort of housing element typically
provided in universal credit
as against um these are average or
benchmark
um uh rental costs
and and you'll see that um the the the
top chart shows uh for the north of
borough
uh and the bottom one for for the south
and the price is
generally slightly higher in the south
um and but what it does show is that
there is a differential
uh between some of those rental
uh costs and the assistance that people
who are in need
will receive with um their their housing
uh requirements so that's another kind
of
um pressure on the system if you like um
now there have been um a number of
programs have been operation through the
pandemic as well
uh and one particularly has been around
um supporting
uh a common temporary accommodation we
have a
scheme called a bed every night that's
operated in in
in greater manchester um and also
uh additional support for rough sleeping
now the picture in traffic as i said
earlier is
actually compared with great ranchers as
a whole we have a
um very limited numbers thankfully of uh
rough sleepers but what we do have are
are a very small number of
uh uh people who live uh lifestyle
the other impact on on the pandemic has
been the fact that we haven't been able
to do some of the work programs
and the tasks and finish groups that we
might have liked to particularly trying
to link
uh get sort of establish those linkages
between health
and homelessness um because simply
because of course the health sector has
been
um under so much pressure but certainly
enough is something we would be
um very keen to pick up on
and overall there are a number of other
challenges
that have really come out of uh kovit 19
um which are set out there uh in
the uh report um but obviously
what we're trying to do is mitigate the
impact on those
so certainly monitoring uh
how the numbers are doing the
performance and so on um
graeme scott early was mentioning how
collaborative working
with other registered providers is
really important and we certainly
would support all of that and that's
really essential
for trying to tackle this on a holistic
level
we can try and provide advice and be
proactive in our advice to people
and you know we continue to operate the
bed every night scheme as well
in the longer term we would be looking
to
increase the provision of a temporary
accommodation and if we are successful
in doing that that will also then drive
down
those bed and breakfast uh placements
um so i hope that provides a an overview
of the service and some of the
challenges and what we might do to
address those obviously uh happy chair
to uh take any questions
thanks very much adrian i think i think
that was very helpful
and it was helpful getting the report to
it as well
prior to the meeting and i think you
know
the things that you've described are
very key
in terms of homelessness and
how we sort of tried to impact
on that so i think there's a lot of
good work going on at this moment in
time so
i thank you for that we've got a number
of
questions and i'll
try and work through them um counselor
dr karen barkley
no you it was that the last yeah that
was the last one that i missed yeah
okay um so
uh there was a point made by
someone around the uh the only
properties that need
recladding that thus could get about
declaring following grenfell were
tht properties but i think the question
was asked around that
um right um council rob
chilton thank you chair um
adrian i think you know what i'm going
to say i have no doubt whatsoever that
trafford trafford residents who find
themselves in these difficulties
are appropriately um helped and
supported i have no evidence that that's
not the case
um that's not my problem my problem is
the people
that manchester city council are shoving
and there is no other word for it
shoving in
miles away from the city on a regular
basis
i mean i know that the encounter people
at um the travel lodge in sale
who have been there for six months um
they
and whilst i appreciate that yours your
primary
duty is to ensure that trafford
residents are supported and
helped out of difficult situations
this has an impact on services because
these people are presenting at the food
bank
they're turning up at church they they
don't know where they are they don't
know where they can access support
um it is and the fact that manchester
had to be brought kicking and screaming
to the point
where they would even tell us that these
people were
being put here demonstrates quite
considerable bad faith on their part in
my opinion
um i would like i think a bit further
detail and update
as to what measures are being because i
mean you know the travelodge is one
thing
the amblehurst is quite another and i
think you my my concerns about that
place are well rehearsed as i have been
rehearsing for the past four years
um and there have been deaths there
already
um and i i am still not happy adrian and
i think i would like some
some assurance and i appreciate that
trafford's duty is to
help and deal with its own residence but
ultimately this is a problem that's
happening in trafford
um and a problem of manchester city
council's um
creation and they really should be
taking better care
of the people who fundamentally are in
their care um
so i think i would like a bit of comment
on or at least
some perhaps a bit further detail
in the later written uh submission
adrian thank you
okay now then thank you councillor
chilton and um well happy to
do both really um uh as you know
we we've we've tried to put a particular
emphasis on on the amblehurst because of
the
issues that you've you've mentioned and
we've
been had regular meetings with
manchester
and also great manchester police as well
just to try and make sure that we have a
coordinated approach there
but i think what what what we're seeing
there is perhaps almost like
a symptom symptomatic of a wider issue
and of course bearing in mind that
people
who do end up at that sort of end of the
system are do
are the those who have you know the most
profound needs and
and often you know the greater
complexities uh in terms of their
requirements
but one of i think the strategic answer
to some of these issues
really is the way that uh greater
manchester whole
places um uh homeless people
um because the reason they're in the
amblehurst is that's part of a wider gm
framework and so what we've tried to do
when it is
ourselves at trafford who along with
other partners who sort of kick this off
is to try and get improvements to that
gm
framework um and also link it not only
in terms of homelessness
but also some of the adult social care
issues as well because i think some of
the problems you allude to
will be people who will be receiving
support from social services who may
have also have mental health issues
um and the risk as you quite out rightly
uh uh lined is that these are things
could happen inside those if we're not
careful so what one of the big things
that we are trying to do
is to make sure that we have a much more
coherent picture across gm
and a revised greater manchester
framework
and with that uh appropriate safeguards
but
that's perhaps something very happy to
elaborate on further
um at a future meeting i must just add
if i may check
to thank you adrian for the work that
you and your team have done on this
because i mean you know
strongly i feel on it so thank you very
much thank you chad
thanks i mean did you just
um on on that point before us
all other members to come in um i mean
we have a responsibility in trafford
for across greater manchester because i
think
um the real reality is that
a lot of homeless people do you know
drag themselves into uh manchester city
center
not necessarily their previous talents
uh so i think that has to be recognized
in in in how we deal with this and i
think
that's why we we were concerned when we
did discuss this last time
and we did make record recommendations
to the executive
uh concerning the fact that um councils
across gm and not actually informing
the the host of a new resident
um who is homeless and
he did a statutory duty to do that and
so so we made a very clear
recommendation that the executive deal
with that issue and
i think adrian mentioned that you know
that that that is being dealt with and i
think it's
absolutely right um but uh
you know i just go back to that point
yeah i think we all have a
responsibility across greater manchester
to
to tackle the homelessness uh
you know crisis that you know we do find
ourselves in
and i think um i think in trafford we do
try
try our best and i like you i appreciate
you know all the work that adrian and
the team have done
uh in trafford and hopefully
you know we'll keep that work going and
we'll have to adapt to
you know some of the things that we find
ourselves having to deal with
and i'm sure that we do right they
um louise
uh dagnol councilman doug know did you
want to
come in because you didn't mention
probably about a previous
uh report um and
could we have a report from one of the
small housing
providers as to their response to this i
think you were talking about the
flooding weren't you
yeah so i do have a question about this
but i'm happy to come in in my own to
yeah yeah okay right um
counselor kevin proctor then and we'll
come back to
you louise okay thanks thank you chair
and uh thank you adrian for your
update it's uh useful to get that that
latest information on what what's
happening and i think you're right to
emphasize
the prevention side it's really that's
really important and
my view is that i think hosts do that
quite well
because that is the key to actually
preventing the difficulties that people
face you know if you can
actually prevent the homeless in the
first place um
it's much much better for well it saves
money and it's much better for the
the person as well my question is um on
the there's a recent trend in terms of
the numbers of
women presented as homeless across the
country
it's a national trend and i wondered if
if that's been replicated in trafford
are we
getting more women presenting us
homeless
than maybe was a few months ago it
because that is quite worrying both in
terms of
the general and even more worrying the
the rough sleeping aspect of it if you
notice more when you come
to rough sleeping and the dangers
associated with that so i just wondered
if
that's happening in trafford and is that
causing any
if it is is that causing any particular
difficulties in terms of
um the numbers of
properties we have available to provide
and the practical difficulties in that
thank you okay
thank you um it's not an issue that's uh
we have particularly noticed so far but
what i can do is try and
uh see if we have any data on that i
mean certainly
the um it is what we do know
is that um there's been a lot of
sort of increase in in domestic
incidents and you know domestic
pressures
um through the pandemic period and and
that is
you know producing unexpected
consequences or or consequences we
weren't necessarily seeing before if you
like
so i could uh so be quite interesting to
see
if we're experiencing that locally so
very happy to
see if we have that that data counselor
yeah yeah i i think it would be really
useful to
you know to have a look at that to see
if there is a trend here
my view is maybe it was due to the
rising number of evictions
that's happening and and as adrian said
the
domestic uh abuse aspect of it during
the kobe period so
there could be factors that that may all
happen it is a national trend but
you know it may not be happening
chaplain but it will be interesting to
find out thank you
okay thanks louise
you wanted to come in you're muted
i'm with you now um i just wanted to to
mention
um i was out in my ward recently
uh which is priory ward and there were a
number of policemen about
and one of them was telling me that they
were actually
looking for somebody from the ambulance
who'd gone missing
so you know obviously they went about
the business and it was nice to see that
they were interested in being supportive
of the people at the amble house
my concern was really whether or not he
was considered a danger to himself or in
fact a danger to the public i just
wondered what
kind of support there is there for
i imagine the majority of people who you
know were very fragile and very
vulnerable
you know why that situation arose
you know that and and i suppose i partly
want to set it in the context of
i very much appreciate the work they're
doing and i also understand our need to
share the burden of manchester because
obviously it is a bit of a draw
um it's just main center but when people
are moved to trafford where perhaps are
less familiar with the surroundings are
they also being moved away
from potential support from family from
friends
is there a continued um
effort to communicate with any previous
social care or social work
or substance abuse support that they
were having in manchester how do those
things work i want to know how they
relate and how it affects
so this this individual who doesn't
exist i don't i don't expect you to know
about it or even to comment on any
individual
i was just interested in the context of
somebody requiring
police to go out looking for them for
their for their own sake of the sake of
the public
how does that work and how does that
person access
the support are we able to provide it
here in trafford or are those links
being established back for them to go
back and get that help from where they
came from
i hope that makes sense yeah no it it
does so thank you councillor dagnol
and and that um absolutely um
very pertinent issue um the
the way it will work is that um when
somebody is placed
they will have a support officer so
there will be
a support of the designated support
officer for every person who is placed
um and one of the things that we've
particularly been quite
keen to promote at the amblehurst is
that uh there are
people know where you know some of the
the basics are you know so where's the
chemist where's the way they can get
food and so on
now some of that has been particularly
challenging during the pandemic because
some of the places that they might
ordinarily go haven't uh
necessarily been open or or available
and of course at one stage we were
providing laying on hot food for that
very reason to
to residents in there um but
more generally and in normal times um
because these issues will still arise
you know
just just in a normal era uh it is
really those
uh housing support officers who are that
you know focal point
uh and that point of contact for uh
people in addition to that there may be
course be
be folk who who have additional support
so it might be around mental health it
might be around social care
and such like but that is um the duty of
the
placing authority to maintain those um
and at times we
we have had to just make sure that all
of that
is you know that residents in there do
know
who to contact you know who to they
can't get access to medication who do
they speak to
those type of things and that's been one
of the issues that we've
when we have done for example welfare
visits that's one of the things we
always check on
is is you know do people know where to
get support so
um it is the network is there
but of course um we have to keep making
sure it's
there all the time and there is never
lesser risk because the
nature of the people tend to be quite
vulnerable but
issues may still occur
okay and all right
and we've got uh
councillor jed carter first and then
councillor barry win stanley
after that
thank you chair um thank you adrian um
my questions around both temporary and
bnb accommodation you gave some numbers
over a six month
uh period showing a degree of
fluctuation uh
i guess there's a couple of questions
one do you have
targets for the level that we
aspire to have numbers on uh temporary
and b b
and secondly there's nothing in there
about the duration of stay
particularly in b b can you comment on
how long those people who are in bnb are
staying in bnb
and what's our aspiration to improve it
if it's not satisfactory
thank you okay well i'm sorry i don't
have the specific
data on on the the sort of average stay
um generally it is the shorter shorter
periods for
for for bed and breakfast as as you
might expect
it's um a it's not very good for the
people concerned and b
it's also generally more expensive for
the public purse
our aspiration is to reduce the use of
bed and breakfast altogether
and really clear about that that's what
we would aim to do
but in order to do that we would need to
have a greater supply of
other accommodation that we can rely on
and i think you can see from
the figures in the report that there is
a there's a kind of fluctuation there
um but i think generally we are always
in the picture that there's just not
quite enough
so our ambition is very much to increase
that kind of accommodation because that
is better
for all concern
thank you adrian um if we don't have
data on the duration of people in
temporary and
bnb accommodation would it be possible
for that to be added as a kpi
in your ongoing measurements
yes certainly and i'm sorry i'm sure i
can circulate that along with the
the the the previous uh requests that we
had for
um for information as well yeah i think
that would be helpful
okay um counselor
barry wynn stanley i'm sorry i've kept
you waiting
i believe i've missed yeah i'm the most
patient of people
said with the straight face
[Music]
first of all thanks to adrian and his
team um
and once we get back to a semblance of
normality
uh when your team is operating out of
more regular premises
i would encourage members to go and
spend the day there because it's one of
the first things i did
when i was elected and to say that is an
eye-opener
is an understatement because we all have
an image of what homelessness is we
think homelessness is the people you
step over in the um
they step over in the street that is
awful to be in that position
the homelessness which uh i saw i saw
the day
when i was i spent the the day with
robin his team a host
was families with children who
both all in work regular normal people
who have been evicted on section 21
through known through no faults of their
own
and i found the whole the holes it was a
complete eye opener for me
um and i found it quite quite shocking
and if any if anybody wants to see how
badly broken the housing
market is go and spend an afternoon with
with hospital
great great sympathy for you adrian and
robin's team there's a question coming
up for us
and it is around the the the
the hidden of hidden evictions due to uh
due to covert
um because it was very interesting
article in the paper a couple of weeks
back
where it said that even even eviction
notices lodged with the costs are at
their lowest level ever
um but there there is a feel amongst the
the the people who work in the sector
that there's an awful lot of hidden
addictions so people are going to become
homeless not in
section 21 but through less less obvious
methods
such as uh just being made to feel
uncomfortable with a living
being threatened with rent increases and
that sort of thing so
do you have any feel for the um uh
for things that fit into that category
so you you you've got
we all experience something of a tsunami
of evictions following um
at the end of the government schemes do
you have any feel for what the total
number would be
including the the the um
the things which we don't which we don't
see about i think what's your expertise
tells you that it tells you were there
even if they're not even if they're not
coming forward does that make that make
sense
it is you know there must be hidden
evictions that happen uh so you know
it it does make sense and that's on top
i'm not the expert adrian t experts yeah
that's why i directed the question to
him chad
i'm certainly not the expert but i'll
i'll try and answer it
uh uh councilman stanley uh i mean i
think the
we we certainly um we normally use the
number of applications as the barometer
i suppose because you're quite right
there are things that
are happening in the housing market um
that we don't
always sort of crop up on the official
statistics if you like
but what we tend to think is that when
people are in trouble
they normally get in touch with the
local authority we we are the
you know when when friends and family
can't help where do you go
you you you you present or you pick up
the phone to
to to the council's housing service so
we tend to use that as
as a bit of a weather bell um and and
at the moment what we've not quite seen
or what we tend to feel is we've not
really seen the full impact
of of the coved era if you like we would
probably
suspect that there is a time lag this is
certainly our concern
is that there will be a rise uh as
as the year progresses um so um
not a full answer i'm afraid um but
um we we are always conscious that there
are those things that are happening
and and i think you can apply this
almost to every area of life that the
sort of the pandemic is doing you know
slightly strange things and unexpected
things
but generally our sense is that there is
there are more pressures to come
and so perhaps in whether it's two
months or four months we're not quite
sure but we
we think the trend will increase over
the year okay
thank you thanks uh
councillor jill paxford
jill oh yeah so yeah i was just
wondering um how much funding there is
available for discretionary housing
payments because they're i mean they're
really important when there's that short
film rent
because of the lha rate and also because
of the benefits cap so i just wondered
um i know i know the you know they're
called discretionary
i've worked for citizens advice so i
just kind of curious as how much funding
or how easy it is to get a discretionary
discretionary housing payment
um i think the position overall is that
funding funding unfortunately is quite
limited
um i think that's probably one probably
what
would be helpful perhaps is if we can
give you some figures on that
uh cancer oxford if that would be useful
um
um because um certainly that's something
that we will we will have the data on
but i think the broad answer will be
unfortunately
it it's it's never quite enough
yeah thank you
yeah okay did anybody else want to
come in no that's a new gross chair
ah right council new growth thank you
thank you very much
um so following on from uh council win
stanley actually uh i was
looking to see i mean we are foreseeing
there's going to be a rise in need as
the eviction
um uh start to increase after covert
i just was asking a capacity question
um perhaps if you could also indicate
the areas that you are using to build
capacity i do remember
recently there being uh trafford news
bulletin that we were using the
long term or we were aiming to use the
long term empty homes
scheme to get those back into use for
our
homeless or our homeless need
i wonder if you could perhaps follow up
on that and give me some more detail
yeah well certainly there is a we
receive a homelessness reduction grant
which um does help us uh with our
um um with our capacity
um and we use that to fund additional
posts so we have
uh in effect more people to to to to
help our residents
um so that's and actually this year we
received slightly more than we were
expecting so that was good news um and
that's been extremely
useful so so that's primarily i suppose
uh that's our main way of trying to
get capacity in the system because a lot
of this is really about just
having the people um you know personal
work
you know it's one-on-one it's about
helping individuals and
we need our staff in place to do that
obviously
um the only other thing i suppose is is
then some of these more strategic
elements which
um mentioned earlier about temporary
accommodation and
that's where we can work with um housing
providers
um so we have our own affordable housing
program
but also we have a affordable housing
project office and we've increased
um have a a extra member of staff
working in that area so that that if you
like
is where some of the perhaps some of the
longer term strategic improvement might
lie
um which will you know to try and get
some sort of
better accommodation um which will
better address these issues but in the
short term
it's really around having the staff to
available to help people in pursuit of
me
so can i just ask a
you know a question that's uh
following on from that because
it was trumpeted empty homes
to be used for homelessness and
it doesn't seem that that is the case
really
because you know i would imagine it's
very difficult to identify where
you know the empty home and all the
legal requirements
that go with that um not
identifying them as such but you know
that
legal reality of uh you know just taking
them over
i don't know whether you can do that or
what had it been done in trafford
have it been done elsewhere in greater
manchester it would be interesting to
know
yeah so thank you chair um uh
it's not being done um uh
not not well as far as i know while i'd
be working traffic whether it's being
done historically i'm not sure but i
think
you if it is a question it's always
attempting issues and you say well
there's an empty property we've got
people in need of accommodation let's
marry the two together
uh and as you've highlighted the the the
two when you come down to the
practicalities
that the two don't always match because
often you do need
a very particular kind of accommodation
to to meet those those temporary needs
um but uh so
in reality probably that's that's
probably not the answer
but but of course what we might do is is
get
through getting better use of our
overall accommodation
and housing stock what of course that
might do is then just create the space
and resource
for provision elsewhere um so that's
probably i think we would say
you know probably better to focus on
purpose-built or purpose
sort of um re-provided accommodation
as as a way to go if you say to me yeah
okay counselor up to you thank you just
on that i mean i know that
the only sort of two or three long-term
voids
in my own world are on streets that are
well out of the way and have such vast
land values
that i don't think the council could be
in a position to to
do the compulsory uh just them and use
it for that it's
unfortunately we're a prisoner of our
own borough's popularity i think it's a
lot easier in some other greater
manchester boroughs
to identify suitable properties and just
on that
given when we have discussed this chair
given that um some members have asked
for
more information and you know this is a
situation that is ongoing
perhaps we might want to keep this on
the table and revisit it if that's
possible
well i mean i mean i thought that anyway
because
we we we did talk about it uh in the
last
municipal year and uh we we felt that we
needed it
periodically you know an update
periodically so that
you know we can keep tabs really on it
and and keep
asking the questions and you know try to
trying to do the best that we you know
we can do as a council
so yeah yeah definitely well i've got
you adrian would you mind just checking
offline that we have had section two or
eight notices for the people in sale
travel lodge
right of course council chilton won't do
all right
yeah that's one of them right
i i think that concludes
this item and it just remained for me to
thank you very much uh adrian for
stepping in and presenting
uh the report to us and i think you know
yourself and the team have done a really
good job
in quite difficult times and difficult
periods so
uh thank you for that and we we look
forward to
seeing you or you know your colleagues
uh
again in a few months time
uh thank you chair and obviously glad
glad to report on the future at the
future meeting
and i think the there has been a number
of questions that you said that you
would
you know write to us and i don't know
whether
um alex has captured some of those as
well
so so thanks thanks very much
appreciated
thank you thanks right we
we now uh turn to
item 10 which is uh the committee
work program for 21 22.
um so we try and set ourselves
up for the for the next uh period of
time
or up to the um
may period and
i i think there are topics that we have
regular updates on like the one we just
we've just had and budget monitoring
and the economic
recovery plans and
active drought travel um you know
they're this cycling walking routes
where where we've had temporary moving
over to
permanence so we there are a number of
items there that we are you know
continuing to
sort of keep a tab on um and i think
they
they they should remain in our work
program
so that the the
the meetings that we have i mean there's
not many in a year
i think it's five in the in the years so
there's not that many
um but obviously we we have an
opportunity
to introduce some um
task and finish groups and
our group have a couple of suggestions
uh that we might want to
consider for task and finish groups one
is the highway maintenance
the potholes etc and having an in-depth
uh look into that
the other one is commissioned services
and procurement obviously we'd have to
scope that to see
you know what what the council
is commissioning for services and
and then pick out one of them to
actually look to see
how how they are procured how they
are improving services
how they actually are working
um and i think it would be an
interesting
topic to look at because i i'm not sure
you know
what services are commissioned
in total there must be a lot um but
obviously we wouldn't
be able to do them all so i think we we
could pick out one and
added to that there is at this moment in
time from the last munich
municipal um year a task and finished
group on
disability access which uh
councillor barry winston me led him
and an imprint an
interim report was sent to
the executive but there is
other parts of that that i know
council valley when stanley wants to
continue
with in terms of access and
you know for the disabled people
so it they're the ones that
um you know we we're suggesting
but it's you know we try and work
together
so uh if if there are other suggestions
and we
will consider it i think we do have to
think about capacity as well we always
have to think about capacity of
officers to be able to support these
and i think task and finish groups work
pretty well because you can meet when
you want to meet
and um but you have to you know at times
have
officer support to to do that
so i i don't know whether there's any
comments that anybody wants to make
[Music]
around that are we happy to
kind of support
yeah i just don't ask a question please
around work plan
um this is very much in the context of
myself and some other members of this
committee
i think probably only about five or six
days since our last induction meetings
um there's a degree of finding our feet
and working out
what's worthy of scrutiny and not and i
don't think i'm exactly there yet
is now the cutoff point for setting
any activities of this group through to
next march or is the facility fight to
fire stuff in
now we've digested some information yeah
i can answer that
and how yeah i i i can answer that
quite easily yes because there are
always
issues that um you know
that you uh come into contact with
uh through the year um
and yeah we we always
consider if somebody says that they you
know
we could do a piece of work i mean what
what
i thought when we were discussing the
homelessness
and and other issues tonight was it was
um around violence for instance
and how we actually deal with that in
this forum right
immediately i thought we'll put a
possible task and finish group
so it's things like that that we we we
can do
throughout the year but recognizing that
um you know we do have
certain limits on the capacity of
officers
um to to do that but
to to support that but members can
and often do work
together without officers
being so it is possible to do to
do that making suggestions is the
process
between meetings to send them to you as
chair or
can yeah i think so i mean i i would
appreciate
if it was you know if it was sent
through through me
but you know i think we we would
consider
together you know uh for the next
meeting or whatever
of this committee because it's not my
decision it is
you know it is everyone's decision and
okay who didn't see anybody else
oh it's
no i'm looking at old ones now so
i don't know is there anybody else who
wishes i think counselling newgross had
a question
all right councillor newgross
i'm glad you're alert well
thank you i was i mean you mentioned
services i was wondering if that would
be uh including amy
the seven year review window and the
whole
well the whole shooting match of that
well we've done that
did we yeah we we have done amy yeah
um so we we made recommendations
it was quite a long
task and finished group that did that
i can send you the report if you so wish
thank you
cheers that's fine
yeah is there any other
points that anybody wants to make we're
happy to go with that for now anyway
i think in relation to task and finish
groups
um alex will send out to members
if they're interested in um in joining
it
you know one of the tasks and finished
groups that have just mentioned
um and then we'll try and elect a
chair to sort of run that
so that's how we've done it previously
okay so if we're
yeah counselor dr carolyn barclay
thank you chair um yeah i mean just
really following up with uh counselor
new gosh if we have had a review
recently
um i don't think it was that recently
maybe maybe it was certainly
pre the pandemic scrutiny committee um
but um i would think it would be a
really good idea to
follow that up that review to see how
well
the recommendations have been
implemented because i certainly think
um the review needs a scrutiny of
um of those recommendations because
clearly we all have issues with it from
time to time so
i would personally if we could include
it in the uh
scrutiny work plan like to see our um
how those recommendations have been
put forward thank you yeah well i think
we we could get a written report or
somebody to come along
to say what's happened in in terms of
the recommendations uh i think there has
been
a review on
the auctions and we've decided that
um at this moment in time it would
probably be too expensive to
to to to come out of the
contract so anyway
i'll get i'll get somebody to um to
to give us some information on that
circulated yeah okay
right so it's us
yeah thank you very much i just i just
wanted to just um say that although
i know we have got the climate emergency
update in september
and there was a task and finished group
i i i think i'm still i think there will
still be
a need to keep scrutinizing what's
happening on climate change in view of
the urgency and i hope that will happen
yeah i think it will yeah thank you but
we've got the
report back yes absolutely yeah thank
you september so
yeah okay thank you
right so all right councillor bus as
well chess update
all right councillor boat
thank you i don't want to drag it out
too much obviously uh
it's just a quick one i'm not sure
whether you
you mentioned it but uh i probably
didn't quite catch it i know
that you've uh suggested two uh topics
there
uh because some people aren't aware of
what those include i mean particularly
like things like procurement because
i mean procurement tends to be fairly
uh there's only a few people that tend
to be able to deal with that i mean
you know i'm just thinking of things
like star procurement which
is a quite a big body that but it's only
two or two people on it or two three
people members on it uh
from the administration so if people had
an idea of what it's going to cover
and i mean obviously highways people
know a bit more about
it would be helpful when they come to
wanting to
be involved or task finish group and
things like that
yeah i mean i think uh clearly
once we set something up we'll have to
scope it
you know you you've got to be able to
scope the work that you're going to do
what you're going to carry out i mean
it's just a title
there at this this moment in time and
it's
mainly the commissioned services that we
have and i think you know you
you make a fair point around the star
which is you know not just us it's a
group of
um authorities that uh do commission
services but i think if we if we get an
idea of of what is being commissioned
right across the authority then we'll be
able to
scope it in a much better way and you
can pick out maybe one
service to to look at in depth to see
how it is actually working and
you know what impact is having um on
that service and the people that we
represent really so
that's my thinking in relation to that
okay
yeah okay
um is only anybody else wants to comment
no right okay
so i think that
um that completes item 10
and we move on to item 11 which is
urgent
business which i don't think we've had
any so
i think that concludes the meeting so
can i
thank you all for your attendance and um
a particular thank you to rob chilton
for standing in and probably doing a
much better job than i i did
i was quite flustered when i got home
i just terrorized people change
yeah is that how you do it then ralph
yeah yeah
i'll learn from that right okay well
well thanks to everybody and um you know
i
really apologize for for not getting on
sooner at the beginning
um and i think the more i tried
the worse it got
the panic started setting i'm not really
good with rit anyway but it's the first
time
actually in the times that we've been
doing this that
i've failed to get on
but uh hopefully it doesn't happen again
so i apologize for that and enjoy the
rest of the evening
cheers now bye how's everyone